Now that you've seen what
a simple convnet looks like,
there are many things that
we can do to improve it.
We're going to talk about three of them,
pooling, one by one convolutions and
something a bit more advanced
called the inception architecture.
The first improvement is a better way
to reduce the spatial extent of your
feature maps in
the convolutional pyramid.
Until now, we've used striding to shift
the filters by a few pixel each time and
reduce the future map size.
This is a very aggressive
way to downsample an image.
It removes a lot of information.
What if instead of skipping
one in every two convolutions,
we still ran with a very small stride,
say for example one.
But then took all the convolutions in a
neighborhood and combined them somehow.
That operation is called pooling, and
there are a few ways to go about it.
The most common is max pooling.
At every point in the future map,
look at a small neighborhood around that
point and compute the maximum
of all the responses around it.
There are some advantages
to using max pooling.
First, it doesn't add to
your number of parameters.
So you don't risk
an increasing over fitting.
Second, it simply often
yields more accurate models.
However, since the convolutions that
run below run at a lower stride,
the model then becomes a lot
more expensive to compute.
And now you have even more hyper
parameters to worry about.
The pooling region size, and
the pooling stride, and no,
they don't have to be the same.
A very typical architecture for
a covenant is a few layers
alternating convolutions and
max pooling, followed by a few
fully connected layers at the top.
The first famous model to use this
architecture was LENET-5 designed by
Yann Lecun to the character
recognition back in 1998.
Modern convolutional networks
such as ALEXNET, which
famously won the competitive ImageNet
object recognition challenge in 2012,
used a very similar architecture
with a few wrinkles.
Another notable form of
pooling is average pooling.
Instead of taking the max,
just take an average over the window
of pixels around a specific location.
It's a little bit like providing
a blurred low resolution view of
the feature map below.
We're going to take
advantage of that shortly.